there are lots of ways  to sort of eat your way to good health  you know diets that are  low in saturated fat that provide good  amounts of unsaturated fat that are rich  in fiber  that have a good amount of plant protein  and are low in ultra processed foods  time and time again lead to good health  outcomes you know these are the people  that are experiencing less  cardiovascular disease less less  likelihood of having a heart attack or a  stroke  less risk of various cancers  and less risk of neurodegenerative  diseases there are many variations of  that  it could be a really well done  pescetarian diet it could be a really  done well done vegetarian diet it could  be a completely plant exclusive whole  food plant-based diet you know any of  those diets if you compare them to a  standard diet and there are a bunch of  studies that have done those you'll see  significant risk reductions for various  diseases